[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAMIAN LAWLOR: We have
lots to cover this morning.
We've also got some really,
really great stories
from customers who are
going to join us up onstage.
So I'm going to speak very
quickly, not just because I'm
Irish, but because I want to get
off the stage as fast as I can
and welcome some
more of my colleagues
and some of those
great customers
up to share their
experiences with you.
So a little bit about myself.
I'll just give you a little
kind of personal journey.
I'm 11 years in Google.
I spent two years running
the Publisher side in Europe,
then I moved across after
the DoubleClick acquisition
and ran DoubleClick for
six years in Europem
and I've been in Cloud for
about three and 1/2 years
at this stage.
And I was really attracted
to the transformation
that was taking place in people
moving from an on-premise world
into a cloud world
and what that could
mean for helping companies
with their own digital
transformation.
But I was particularly
interested,
coming out of the ad tech world,
about what cloud computing
could do to really help
people with their marketing
and how they could interact
with their own customers.
So I saw it as a compelling
transformation story
as the consumer shift to
mobile, which we all saw,
or the shift to
programmatic advertising.
So if you think of those two big
shifts, another really, really
large shift that we're
seeing, and I love this quote
from Gartner, is,
this transformation
of how many marketers see that
they'll be "competing mostly
or completely on the basis
of customer experience in two
years' time."
The quote's from 2017.
That means that it should
actually be happening now.
So just a quick question
to the audience.
The marketers who
are in the room,
are you now mostly or
completely competing
on the basis of customer
experience or not quite yet?
So yes?
OK.
That's pretty interesting.
And I think one of
the reasons why--
nothing's really
changed in marketing.
Marketers are still looking
to acquire, retain, and grow
customers.
And they want to put the
customer in the center
and focus on
customer engagement,
and really want to
focus on what we
call creating delightful
customer experiences.
And that's going to help you
to predict how much people will
spend in the future,
predict is your customer,
is she likely to spend again,
how do we find others like her
at scale, et cetera.
So you've got all
of these touchpoints
from your customers,
all of this fantastic
data you're collecting, but
a lot of that data is sitting
in either technological silos
or in organizational silos
in your organization.
And so that makes it very
hard to get a complete view
of your customer.
So your email marketing team
may have fantastic insights
in your customers,
but is not sharing
that with your search team.
And you may not be getting
feedback back fast enough
to your product development or
your customer service teams.
And you may also
be working with--
I know there's a stat out
there that on average people
use 13 different
marketing technologies.
But in fact, even
somebody today told me
that, actually, the
different tools that collect
data that sit in silos
numbers in the thousands
in their organization,
and how difficult
it is to actually pull
all that data together.
So this is what
really interested me.
So when I started off in Cloud,
I did a global round trip, just
going and meeting as many
CMOs and C-suite CEOs,
and pretty much asking them
the same question, which was,
how satisfied are you
with your own ability
to understand your own
data on your own customers?
And I always tell
the joke that I
have 100% record
of people saying
they are very dissatisfied.
And the joke is that
there was actually
one CMO who told me that
they were very satisfied
with the amount of the
value and insight they
got from their own data.
So that kind of
broke my 100% record.
But then afterwards, they
came back up to me and said,
I only said that because
I was in front of my team,
and I didn't want
to embarrass them.
In fact, we're really unhappy
with how much value we can get
out of our own customer data.
So what that actually means is
that the statistic behind me,
where 13% of
organizations say they're
making the most of their
available customer data
is exactly 13% more than I'd
met in actual discussions
with all of you.
And what I find
really interesting
is that the more sophisticated
the enterprise that we work
with get, the less
satisfied they
become with the amount
of value that they
can get out of their
own data, because it
feeds their requirement.
If they do start seeing
how fantastic insights
they can pull out
of their own data,
then they want to get
more and more insights.
They want to start using
machine model, learning models.
They want to make it faster
to get to those insights.
They want to be able to
use smarter technologies.
And they want to make
it easier for all
of the people in
their organizations
to be able to get to
those insights quickly.
So this is where Cloud
for Marketing comes in.
Our overall vision is to
take what is typically,
for a lot of people, this linear
model of the data journey--
collecting your data,
transforming it, analyzing it,
visualizing it,
and activating it--
and offering faster, simpler,
and smarter solutions
for you to create these
delightful customer
experiences from your data and
from your marketing technology,
and ultimately, with the
power of cloud computing,
to turn that more linear
model into a virtuous circle.
Because, obviously, as you
activate these campaigns,
as you activate these
delightful customer experiences,
then customers react
and supply more data
about what their preferences
are and what they want from you.
And 63% of consumers
say they want
brands to understand
them better and use
the data from their
purchasing history
to provide them with a
more personalized solution.
And what we're here to
do is to bring technology
to bear on that to enable
you to do that more
and more with your customers.
So to go into more
detail about how
we're looking to turn
that vision into reality,
I'd like to welcome my colleague
Biren Kalaria up onstage,
who's the global strategy
lead for Cloud marketing.
Thank you, Biren.
BIREN KALARIA: Cheers, Damian.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
So I'm going to talk to
you about three things
before bringing up three amazing
customers who are going to come
and share their experiences.
So the first thing
I'm going to cover
is how you can get
started with us.
Secondly, why you
should work with us.
And thirdly, going to give
you a bit of a product
preview to show how we're
making that process that you
saw earlier from Damian
even more faster, simpler,
and smarter.
So the first thing
that we've done--
and I hope a few of you were
here with us last year as well,
but we've developed
a set of solutions
based on high-value
use cases that we've
heard in conversations with
enterprises over the past two
years.
These are eight
use cases that are
packaged to be as turnkey
and high-impact as possible.
And each of the use
cases is designed
to help you make
more of your data
in service of both long-
and short-term goals whilst
minimizing the initial
financial investment required
to implement, and
also delivering
you a fast time to insight.
So we've got an email
address that you
can contact the team on at
the end of the presentation.
And if you're interested in
getting a little bit more
detail on these solutions,
please do drop us a note,
and also make sure you
pop over to our booth
down in the main expo to
speak more to the team.
The second area that
we've put a lot of work
into over the last
12 months in terms
of putting in things
to help you succeed
have been around our partners.
So you know that partners are
an incredibly important part
of the overall cloud and
Google Cloud ecosystem.
We've done a few things there.
I'll just touch on a few things.
So we have 12 marketing
analytics specialized service
partners available today.
And this list is
growing all the time.
In fact, we'll be launching this
specialization more formally
during the course of this week.
Specializations, as you know,
are awarded to GCP partners
with industry-leading
competencies.
And these partners
are there to help you
from the very earliest point in
your journey to Google Cloud.
So those are the folks
on the left-hand side.
On the right-hand
side, you have a number
of data integration partners.
And these broadly fall
into three buckets.
The first group, the kind
of ETL and data partners,
through these companies, you
can access over 300 connectors
to data sources that you really,
really, really care about.
And with these
connectors, you can
be sure that the data from the
marketing channels that you
want and the sources that
you really care about
is always up to date and
accessible in BigQuery.
The connectors themselves very
quickly scale to your needs
whilst promoting kind
of agile workflows
that require less planning and
fewer resources to maintain.
The second group there are
the analytics partners.
So working with our
BI partners, we've
created business dashboards with
preconfigured templates which
provide robust analytics to
help you understand and analyze
your marketing data.
And the third group are
marketing technology partners
themselves.
So these are companies that
are inherently built on GCP,
and can provide you with
that kind of SaaS layer
that you need, or
the technology layer
that you need, to actually
make more use of any data
that you have already sitting
on Google Cloud Platform.
So we've put a lot of
work into these areas.
Lots of the different
keynotes this week
will touch on various folks
in these ecosystems as well.
Secondly, I just want
to touch on a little bit
why we're different.
And this is one of
the first breakouts
I hope that you'll
be attending today
and through the
course of the week.
But just want to touch
on a few points here.
As you know, GCP is a
leader in smart analytics.
Forrester rated Google
as the only leader
in their Insight's
platforms-as-a-service report
last year.
Secondly, we have solutions
designed to meet market needs.
So we're going to touch on
some of those in a little bit.
Like the use cases we
just walked through
and the console that I'll
be showing you in a moment,
we make it easier for
marketers to deploy workloads
on Google Cloud Platform and
generate time to insight very,
very quickly.
And of course, we
do a lot of work
and we are a leader in
the machine learning space
with technology that is truly
different than any other
in the market.
We have over 7,500
projects powered by AI,
including Google's consumer
products from Search
through YouTube through Maps.
Secondly, to the differentiators
in the marketing analytics
space, I want to touch
on points that you
may have heard in the keynote
earlier this morning about why
our cloud is different
from other clouds.
Firstly, security
is at its core.
Google infrastructure
was born in the cloud
and built from the ground
up with security in mind.
Secondly, our fully managed
serverless offerings
eliminate that
operational complexity
that is required when
moving to cloud, and making
cloud easy to adopt.
And thirdly, openness
is in Google's DNA.
From our commitment to open
source software in areas
like TensorFlow and Kubernetes
to the way in which we build
our products to give
you flexibility,
our open approach
means that you can
develop applications that are
easy to run and fast to deploy.
And finally, we're bringing
you the best of Google
for your marketing needs.
Google is inherently
deeply entrenched
in the marketing space through
all the work that's done
on the ad side of our business.
And we have integrations
with other Google products,
like the Google Marketing
Platform, Google Ads, Maps,
Play, and YouTube, that help
you get more from these products
and from Google Cloud.
And we've also looked to
bring you the best of Google
for marketing, bringing
technology developed
at Google, like the Vision API,
to help solve for marketing use
cases.
And Google has teams with
decades of experience working
with enterprises of every
size in every industry
and in every nationality to
help solve your marketing
challenges with our technology.
So we talked about how we're
helping enterprises today
through the use cases
that we've packaged up
with the cloud, kind of hexagons
that are available to everyone.
And I just want to
give you a sneak peek
into what we're building to
make that data journey that you
see on the screen right now even
faster, simpler, and smarter.
So the Cloud for
Marketing console
is our first step
in helping customers
solve marketing use
cases faster, simpler,
and smarter on GCP.
And it's in alpha now and
available in every region.
If you're interested
to see more than what
I'm going to show you
in the next few slides,
please do head over to
our booth in the main hall
to speak to our PMs
and engineering teams.
So firstly, when a
user opens the console,
their dashboard will show
the following things--
templated queries, links to
templated visualizations,
starting with Data Studio,
predictive models that
are available at the
click of a button,
and activation points as well.
And I'll touch on these four
things now very briefly.
Firstly, we've made it
faster to collect data.
We've simplified the
manual upload process
for getting data into BigQuery
by providing the tools
and step by step
instructions you
need directly in the
console, allowing
you to get your data in faster.
Secondly, managing all
your marketing-related data
is simpler with built-in
tagging and access controls.
We've created a universal
schema for web analytics, which
allows customers to execute
queries against the same schema
and combine data from
Google Analytics and Adobe
for more comprehensive
analysis and reporting.
And you can maintain
data privacy and security
by managing access controls
right down to the column
level for sensitive
NPII data as well.
Super cool.
This is the last area.
The console provides smarter
insights about your customers
and products, leveraging
templated queries
and the same predictive
models that power Google's
other products.
No coding needed.
Firstly, templating
queries, they
answer common e-commerce
analytics questions and output
to a UI with the results.
Secondly, customers
can use our models
to predict lifetime
value and forecast
demand using a simple UI.
Again, no coding required.
The demand forecasting model
is using Google products
to forecast ad demand
and search trends,
and now we're making that
available to our customers
through the console.
And the last piece here
are the activation points.
So once you have
done your analysis
and you run some
predictive models,
you can, of course, get a raw
output of audience segments
that you can then use to push
into any of the marketing
tools of your choice.
We also have an
integration with SendGrid
that allows you to push
those lists directly
into that platform
if you're using it
for email marketing purposes.
So that's a little bit about
the console and a little bit
about what we've
been up to to date.
And I hope you're excited
about the opportunity
to run your marketing
analytics on Google Cloud,
and the work that we're
doing in this area.
Like I said, don't forget to
come and see us in the booth.
And today, we're
actually incredibly
lucky to be joined by leaders
from Ulta Beauty, American
Eagle, and Colgate
to come and share
how Google Cloud helps them
supercharge their marketing
data.
First up, we have Ben
Pham, senior architect,
and Faris Alqadah, senior
director, Data Science
Innovation, from Ulta Beauty.
Welcome onstage, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
FARIS ALQADAH: Thank you.
Hello, everyone.
So I'm Faris.
This is Ben.
Like he said, senior
director of Data Science
Innovation at Ulta.
And we're happy
to share our story
with you of what we're currently
building using Google Cloud
Platform.
Just a little bit about
Ulta Beauty to give context.
So we are the largest
US-based beauty
retailer with just over 1,000
locations in all 50 states now.
So a lot of things differentiate
Ulta Beauty, but one main thing
that sticks out to me, and
learning since joining,
is that the beauty retail
landscape has traditionally
been segmented across
price point and brand.
So at Ulta Beauty, we
break that segmentation.
We actually carry
across all price points
and across 500 brands.
So we carry about 25,000 SKUs.
Also, each of our locations
offers a full salon service
with skin, brow,
and hair services.
So it's really a very
different beauty experience
when a customer walks into
Ulta Beauty than what they're
traditionally accustomed to.
Now, this gives us
great differentiation,
and it also presents its
own challenges in marketing,
because we have such a
diverse guest profile.
So our vision for
what we're trying
to achieve in terms of marketing
and customer experience,
I think, is no different
than what most retailers are
trying to do.
What we really want
to do is enable
seamless and
personalized experiences
across all touchpoints.
So for a guest that walks
into our salon regularly
and has a stylist that
knows her preferences
and can give her
great tips, we want
her to have that
exact same experience
if she logs onto the Ulta app.
And so that's quite a challenge
with today's marketing
landscape when we have all these
different disparate systems
with different data stuck
in all those channels.
But that's our vision.
And furthermore, we want to
go beyond the traditional
marketing push mentality.
Where we've traditionally used
these channels of marketing
to merely push content and
push users to perform actions
to purchase or to
engage with us,
we really want to make that
more of a two-way conversation
with guests, so, one, to
make them feel more engaged
with Ulta Beauty, but also
to collect valuable data
and to make their
experience better.
So with this vision, we
identified three main core
capabilities that we think
are essential to enable
this vision.
So, one, we need the
ability to collect,
link, and apply machine learning
to all this disparate data
at scale.
Second, we need the flexibility
to take source systems
in and out of that
data collection process
without disrupting the
rest of the workflow.
We also need the flexibility
to enable that intelligence
that we're garnering
through our machine learning
to any of these channels.
So that flexibility
is key, so we
don't go into the
cycle of collect
in batch, run machine
learning, and then market,
because for today's customer,
that might be too late.
And that brings us to
the third capability,
that we really needed
real-time integrations,
so that if a customer
is on the site,
is on mobile, or
has just transacted,
we identify that immediately,
not two or three days later,
and we can react to them.
So by identifying those
three main capabilities that
were needed and for
our vision, we're
actually in the
process of building
two Cloud-native platforms.
So one is
conversational commerce,
and so a Cloud-native,
through Google Platform.
The second is our
personalization engine that
will enable these experiences.
And so Ben is going to talk to
us about the first platform,
conversational commerce,
and some use cases
that we're building
through that.
BEN PHAM: Thanks, Faris.
So as Faris
mentioned, our vision
is to make a guest's every
touchpoint personalized and
relevant.
So we built a compressive
conversation platform
for our guests.
And this platform will enable us
to provide two-way conversation
with a guest across
these touchpoints
and then on multiple
avenues and channels.
So these two demo video
that we show here,
are what we call a Beautybot and
Virtual Beauty Advisors, which
were built on this platform.
The one at the bottom is what
we call Virtual Beauty Advisors,
which just helps our guests
to find their skin care needs
and finding their products
for their skin care
needs and concerns.
And in this case,
Virtual Beauty Advisors
provide advice and
guidance to find
the right products for
their skin care needs
and which go through
the conversation of AI
and then which recognize
the daily skincare routine,
their skin type based
on their skin concern,
and then make the relevant
offers and recommendations.
And that Beautybot on the top
is that the guests they did not
receive their missing reward
points for their purchase,
and they have the receipt
to prove their purchase.
So they start interacting
with our Facebook Messenger,
and they start
initiate a conversation
with our Beautybot.
And within our platform,
we have an NOP engine
that predicts the
intent of the message.
And in this case, it is
the missing reward points.
And then the Beautybot
starts to engage the guest,
asking them or looking
up their account,
get their details about
their transactions.
And then by asking them to
take a photo of their receipts,
and then add their missing
point to their reward points.
So now, I'm going to
hand over to Faris
to talk about the
personalization platform.
FARIS ALQADAH: Yeah.
So as we mentioned,
we're building both
these platforms cloud native.
And both of these platforms rely
on each other, use each other.
Just as we described, our
vision is to enable intelligence
on any channel.
So conversational
commerce is definitely
one channel across social,
email, bots, et cetera.
At the center of all that
is what we're building,
called our
personalization platform.
And to give some
context, in beauty,
personalization is essential.
The very nature of beauty
is very personal to guests.
It's also, within this domain,
beauty is not a necessity.
It's something that's fun.
It's something
that our 30 million
loyalty members are
very passionate about.
So it's become clearer
and clearer to us
that engaging with them and
understanding our guest's
preferences and being
very targeted with them
is something that's essential.
So the current state
of our marketing,
but also customer
experience, is pretty good.
We have very rich
data on our customers.
Like we had 30 million
loyalty members.
95% of our revenue is generated
by those loyalty members.
So we have a rich data set
with pretty strong marketing
capabilities in
our current state.
But I think, like
most retailers,
we're trying to go beyond
that and future-proof it.
So currently, we're very
segment based, very batch
and channel-specific marketing.
Where we want to get to with
our personalization platform
is to be truly one-to-one,
to be real-time and go
beyond segments.
Furthermore, not be
reactive, but be proactive
and predictive.
And so, how are
we achieving that?
Well, by using
Google Cloud Platform
to bring in all the data
from all the sources,
going beyond transactions.
So if a guest transacts with
us, it's almost too late
to market to them.
But going beyond transactions
and looking at all the signals,
maybe through
conversational platform,
maybe through what they're doing
on our sites or other channels,
and then feeding all
that to real time machine
learning and not batch-based,
and enabling those capabilities
to be shared across
every channel using
a flexible infrastructure and
service-based architecture.
So Ben will actually
show some of what
that looks like under the hood.
BEN PHAM: So now we know
what the conversation
and personalization
platform are,
but how do we make
it all possible?
So this is the overview
of our architecture design
that show how do we leverage
Google Cloud Platform to make
it all possible for us.
So first, we use the cloud
identity and security
to manage users, roles, groups,
services account in GCP.
And the goal for us is to
maintain a privileged access
model that we want to make sure
that every team, every members,
every individual, are
assigned to the right access,
public access, required
for them to do their job.
And also, we want to make sure
that the GCP identity access
management roles and
privileges are assigned
to the groups, not individual.
And then we manage these
groups and the group membership
within our Alta
Active Directory.
And we push these groups to
GCP via Google Cloud Directory
Sync.
So yeah, first you can see here
the ingest the store layer.
Then this is the
layers where we have
both platforms are running on
this layer, on the Google Cloud
Compute Engine, listening
to the real-time event
from the external systems,
such as the Facebook Messenger,
as the web hook, as you've seen
earlier in the Beautybot video.
And then that web hook is
hosting on the cloud network
services sending
the event directly
to the conversation platform.
And on the left-hand
side, we also
see the [INAUDIBLE] system can
send the data via data stream
or batch into our platform
via the Cloud Pub/Sub.
Within the
conversation platform,
we have a interplay
component, which
is orchestrate all the
incoming and outgoing traffics
in the front, and also
communicate with our NLP engine
for the message intent
or intent message--
for example, the missing reward
points that we saw earlier.
And then also,
interacting with what
we call it the quasi running
inside the personalization
engine.
This is the place where we
have a complete 360 data
view of our guests with
real-time intelligent models.
And then also, it's playing the
key role in the Virtual Beauty
Advisor that we saw earlier.
So now, we have the data coming
from the batch, data streaming,
real-time event, real-time
data integration flowing
into that ingest and store.
How do we store all this data?
So the answer, we use
the cloud storage,
what we specify as
unstructured raw data.
And then the
important thing is, we
want both platform
be able to use
and read the data
from the cloud storage
for our continuous
machine learning,
machine training,
models training,
is a switching point for us.
And now next layer, we have
the process and transformation,
which we use the Cloud
Dataflow to process and enrich
the data into our BigQuery as
our analytics data warehouse
and also the BigTable
and DataStore
for our in-house
application use,
which is sitting in the
analyze and explore layer.
And lastly, we also
enable our DevOps team
to use Stackdriver's
container registry
for logging, monitoring,
CI/CD pipeline file platforms.
So now we all know how
GCP is playing a key role
in our marketing
platform, enable
us to surround our guests
for every touchpoint.
But at the same time,
we want to make sure--
it's important point for us
to apply our infrastructures,
standards, practices, on top
of GCP for the long term.
So here's a few key
highlights that we
set as our GCP foundation.
For example, backup
recovery strategy.
We need to make sure that we
have defined the region zones,
disaster recovery.
We had the big automation
for scalability.
We also need to integrate
DevOps, our standard tools
for monitoring and operations,
governance strategy
around the technical support,
optimization processes,
best practices, and also
compute engine and storage
standards for the OS
patching, licensing, pattern
for the machine type
and cloud storage.
And security risk,
also important for us
to continue to manage the
user roles and groups.
And then lastly, the networking.
We need to make
sure that we apply
the shared VPC clients via
VPN, and DNS, and all of that.
Thanks, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BIREN KALARIA: Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
And next up, we
have Chris Stephens,
who's the Vise President
of Data and Technology
from American Eagle Outfitters.
And I will not take the
clicker with me this time.
There you go, Chris.
Thank you, very much.
CHRIS STEPHENS:
I was just telling
my team I didn't
know I was allowed to
have friends up here.
So all the work I'm
about to talk about I
didn't do, by the way.
Some people out here
in the audience.
Raise your hand if
you did the work.
There we are.
Alrighty.
So I'm Chris Stevens.
I work for American
Eagle Outfitters.
And I'm going to talk a
little bit about what's
it like to be your customer.
You saw when the Google
Marketing Platform focuses
around customer journey and
understanding that journey
with your customer.
And we've spent a lot of work
partnering with our CX and UX
team to actually build out a
really comprehensive customer
journey that I'm going to
talk a little bit about.
And then I'm going to
talk about the work
that my team is doing to measure
and understand that for each
and every customer, every time.
OK.
So first, American
Eagle Outfitters,
if you don't know who we are, we
really are two primary brands--
American Eagle brand, maker of
the best jeans in the world.
By the way, the number one
women's jeans brand in America,
if you didn't know that.
And also the women's
brand, Aerie.
So American Eagle is
all about empowering
youth and individuality.
Aerie is really about
celebrating real beauty
in young women.
So I say these
pronouns we and us,
because the reality
is I'm a vice
president of something-or-other
at a $4 billion company.
I didn't do this work, my
team did all this work.
OK.
So you heard a lot
about you've got
to understand who
your customers are,
what they want, what
are their intentions,
how do you use machine
learning and technology,
and so on, to make
sure you're there
when they want you to be there?
And I think for us, it comes
down to listening, right?
You've got to be there
listening and engaging
in a meaningful conversation
with your customer, every time,
when they're ready to
engage in that conversation.
So if you don't know
this Ramones song,
the next line is, you
gotta learn to listen
or you're going to get burned.
So I think, for us, it's really
about listening to our customer
and understanding who they
are at the moment when they're
signaling intent.
So this is a Googleized
representation
of a high level picture
of about 10 people's
five years worth of work.
We have this really
comprehensive customer journey
map that our team has done
that I can't share with you.
It's terribly proprietary.
But you can understand
the idea is,
as a customer's
engaging with us,
they go through these
phases of engagement,
whether it's from
influences to consideration
into in-store digital browsing,
purchasing, usage, returns,
and so on.
And you know, the CX
team, like I said,
did all of this incredible
work mapping out the journey,
doing ethnographic research,
talking to customers,
understanding what it is
like to be that customer
when they're engaging
with our brands.
And then you see the little
gray call-out box there.
That's really the call-out
then to the technology team,
or my team in particular, in
that our job is to understand
and measure what's happening
for 20 million people at a time
as they move through
this customer journey.
So it's important.
You know, we're a
business, so we've
got to tie this back to what
we do as a business, right?
So we have OKRs and
metrics in place
that help us
measure this journey
and understand
what's important--
so things like conversion,
revenue per visitor,
average order volume.
Those are things that are
important to online retailers--
Ulta guys, right?
I hope.
And then we put metrics
and goals in place.
So we want to move
conversion by 2%, let's say.
We want to increase average
order volume to $50 and so on.
And those are
quantifiable things
that we can understand
as we measure
customer interaction, how
they shop, what they buy,
what they browse, and so on.
But then the last part, which
can be the hardest piece--
and I'm going to talk a little
bit about what we're doing
there--
is how do customers
feel about it when
they're interacting with us?
How does it feel
to be our customer?
Not how many of them are there?
What do they buy?
What did they buy
with this other stuff,
and how can I make them
buy more of that stuff?
But how do they feel?
What do they say?
But not one at a time,
how did they feel
and what did they say 20 million
at a time, all of the time,
every time?
And how can I be there
listening as they're
telling me those things?
So two themes I'm
going to talk about.
One is personalization.
So similar to what
the Ulta guys said,
we have a pretty comprehensive
personalization program
under way.
We've got a lot of those
capabilities built out
on the Google Cloud, thanks
to my awesome team again.
But again, we're not just
doing personalization
for personalization.
And quite frankly, we're not
even just doing personalization
to be there for
the customer when
they want us to be and so on.
We are running a
business, so we want
to make sure we're
doing personalization
in a way that ties
back to the things
that our business cares about.
So calling out four
particular examples--
when we engage customers
in one-to-one experiences,
we see significant
revenue impact.
I think the number there
is 21%, or something
like that, of our
customers that don't
interact with our
personalization tactics.
Similarly, on the
conversion side,
we see like 4x conversion
over customers that don't
interact with personalization.
So this might be a sales
pitch for personalization.
Increased units and outfitting--
so we're a fashion retailer.
We sell clothes, so we
want to make sure customers
are outfitting themselves.
They're not just coming for
one particular item or another.
But we want them to
understand the outfitting
intention of our merchants.
And so we see--
I forget there-- it's 18%
or 19% increase in the units
the customers are
buying when they're
interacting with our
personalization tactics.
And then similarly, for higher
revenue and margin per sale.
So the point is that the
team is doing amazing work,
and it's having an impact.
And it's technically interesting
and invigorating, I think,
to come to work every day
and work on this stuff.
Then we can go talk to the board
of directors about the impact
we're having in 4x
conversion and 28%,
or whatever it is, increase
in average order volume.
Those are meaningful numbers
for the board of a $4 billion
public company.
So how do we do that?
This is just a quick overview.
Again, my team's here, if you
want to ask them questions.
But you know, we have
the problem that Damian
talked about at the beginning.
We've got all this data.
It doesn't natively
exist in Google.
So on the left,
your left, we've got
to get all this data
in there to personalize
people's experiences.
I've got to have customer data,
product data, browse data--
tf-idf is an awesome
recommendation based on text
distance frequency for
items in our catalog
and our assortment--
and all this customer
data in there
so that we can understand who's
looking for what, what they
might be interested in adjacent
to what they are browsing
at the time, right?
So we put it through
this pipeline on Google,
apply some machine learning-- we
have this robust recommendation
engine that we built--
and serve those out in real-time
in a recommendation service
that we built that runs an
app engine that our site can
call in real-time.
I don't have a
similar architecture,
but we also have a
real-time pricing and offer
service that we run similarly.
So our customer can
come to the site
and, based on segmentation
work that we do,
I could make pricing and offer
recommendations or promotion
recommendations
to that customer,
based on, you can
imagine, similar logic.
OK so voice of the
customer-- so this is about,
how does it feel
to be our customer?
And how do I measure that?
So a lot of this gets back
to sentiment analysis,
as you can imagine.
But again, we're
trying to tie this
back to running a business.
So our vision here
is putting content
about what customers are
saying and how they're
feeling about our products
and our experiences
into the hands of the
people in our business
that are responsible
for those things.
So you can imagine our
sourcing and manufacturing
team really care if
our jeans are smelly,
if they're bleeding, if they're
tearing out at the seams,
if the fabric is pilly,
those kinds of things.
And you can get anecdotal
one off here and there.
A customer said this,
customer said that.
We got 10 returns in
the distribution center
because of this thing.
But through the service
that we're building here,
we can put dashboards
in front of those teams
and measure every interaction
that our customer has
and everything they say
every time about how
they're feeling about
every one of our products.
So I think that's going to be
pretty powerful for that team,
similarly, for the
merchant teams.
So the job, if you don't know
the job, of retail merchant
is to figure out what
clothes to put together
into an assortment,
how those things ought
to go together at scale.
We sell 60,000
different units a year,
so that's a big
problem to solve.
And then anticipate
what they think
people are going
to like, and then
try to read that through the
season to understand what
people are feeling
about the products
that they put out there
in their assortment.
And sometimes, things move
faster and slower than they
thought they were going to.
And we can use sentiment
analysis or our voice
of the customer engine here to
help them understand not just
this thing's moving slow,
market down, drive-through
the inventory.
That's kind of retail 101.
But maybe the things are moving
slow because of something else.
And people are saying something
about the products, right?
And so we ran an
example last year
where it was around
this time of year.
And our men's shorts were
sort of selling slow.
And the merchants felt really
good about the assortment
they had put together, but
it was just selling slow.
And in a traditional
retailer, you'd
think, well, OK,
it's selling slow.
We've got to move
this inventory.
Mark it down.
Get it out of here.
Take a hit on margin and
suffer for that, right?
But through looking at
our voice of the customer,
we were able to see that,
by and large, customers
were feeling pretty good
about the assortment.
They were saying
positive things.
They liked how the
assortment looked.
product felt, right?
But it just wasn't selling.
So we were able to kind of hold
the line with some confidence
to say, no, people like this.
And it's not just,
hey, do you like this?
It's hey, everybody, 20 million
of you at the same time,
how do you feel
about this stuff?
Do you like it?
And the customers
are saying, yeah,
we kind of like this stuff.
So we kind of were able to hold
the line in terms of markdowns.
And then by the
way, the business
came back and did great.
So it was just kind
of one other indicator
to help us have some
confidence in the assortment
that we'd put together.
OK.
So similarly, the
pipeline, again--
to Damian's point at
the very beginning--
the problem is that I
have all of this data.
It doesn't natively
exist on Google, right?
I have product reviews.
I have purchase surveys.
We have social media data.
We have data from
our call center.
From the call center,
we have chats.
We have calls.
We have emails.
There's a lot of things that
people are saying, right?
Returns data-- there's
surveys on the returns.
We have to bring
all of that stuff
together and amalgamate
it into one thing,
so I can understand
with one taxonomy, what
are people saying?
And how do they feel?
And that's where this kind
of sentiment analysis engine
lays on top.
And then for now, we're kind of
natively building in Tableau.
If there's a Tableau
person in here, shout-out.
Kind of natively building a
little app interface in Tableau
so that our merchant teams
and some of the business
folks I talked about can
interact with that data.
OK, I wanted to talk about
a voice of a real customer.
You know, Aerie was the
first brand to not retouch,
to not airbrush our models.
And we've kind of taken that one
step further in the past year,
and we've actually
recruited real women
to be a part of our marketing
and advertising campaigns.
And if you go to
our website and you
want to see how we merchandise
our products on the website,
those are all real women
wearing our clothes.
And so you can see in
this particular example--
I think there's a laser here--
so this young woman
was on our site.
And she had had a
heart transplant.
So she has one of
these big zipper scars
down the middle of her chest.
And we just so happened to
have another young woman
in a similar condition who
was merchant modeling some
of our clothes on the website.
And you can read for
yourselves, but you
can see that something
along the lines of she
went to bed feeling a little
more comfortable with herself
that night, based on
what we were doing.
So you know, it's not just
machine learning, and AI,
and reasoning over
people's intent to try
to sell them more stuff.
No.
I think the reality is
that if you do it right,
you're listening
to your customers,
you're paying attention to what
they say and how they feel,
and you can have a real
impact on people's lives.
BIREN KALARIA: Last
up today, we've
got Tim Booher, who is the
Global Analytics Lead and Chief
Information Security Officer
from Colgate-Palmolive.
Tim, please come on stage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM BOOHER: Great.
Thanks for the
opportunity to tell
the story of how, at Colgate,
we're using this technology
to really pull together a bunch
of different data sources,
empower our users,
and have a lot of fun.
For those of you that don't
know Colgate-Palmolive,
we have over 3 and 1/2 billion
customers for different product
lines, home care, pet care,
personal care, and oral care,
which is the majority
of our business.
Very global country,
with the majority
of our sales outside
the United States.
Very established in
developing countries.
And you can imagine that
makes a big challenge for us
to understand, with such a
diverse group of customers,
what they think about our
products, what they want,
and how they respond to
all of our creative work
that we're doing.
My background before
coming into Colgate
was with the US government.
I had the opportunity to
run part of DARPA's machine
learning portfolio.
Whether it was fighting
human trafficking networks,
using AI to infiltrate
terrorist networks
and find radicalization,
or trying to put terrorists
behind bars before
they could act,
all that required us going
out and getting data.
We didn't look for a
tool that provided that.
We found the smartest
people we could.
We built everything
using open source,
and we had all the computing
power that we wanted.
I also had hundreds of people
and millions a year to do it.
When you're in a commercial
construct, what's amazing
to me is everything that that
I got mostly from organizations
like MIT that built
everything in C
and were able to do entity
extraction and all this work,
you can get instantly
now on Google's cloud.
And that's incredibly
exciting to me,
because we can get a
lot done very quickly.
In this case, we looked
at consumer sentiment
as a starting point.
And it really opened
the door for us
to do a lot of other
exciting things.
The first experiment
we did with Google
is we looked at several
hundred thousand reviews
of our customer's
products online, then
wrote a bunch of
Python glue code
to fit together
all the master data
and add some structure to
the data that was out there,
and then used Google's
Natural Language API.
And this still floors
me a little bit
because I had hundreds of
people building capability
that got about half
of what this has.
And we were doing some
really awesome stuff with it.
But here, I can
use a smaller team,
Cloud infrastructure,
scale up what we need,
and get a lot of work
done more quickly.
What's amazing about
this is entity extraction
used to be one of our hardest,
most technical problems.
It comes out of the box,
along with sentiment score,
salience of how relevant,
and even magnitude
of feeling on different
topics that are there.
Once we can do
entity extraction,
that's where it gets
really exciting.
Because even when we
start with reviews,
depending on the business user--
and there are eight different
business users that are
now using this data,
everything from supply
chain, to e-commerce,
to product development,
to marketing--
because it's one BigQuery
data set, a number of users
can do a lot of
different things with it.
And because we can rearrange
blue hexagons pretty quickly,
we can be agile and respond to
our business needs out of that.
The first set of metrics
we looked at, though,
were looking at
consumer sentiment
across a variety of
brands and topics,
doing the entity
extraction from that,
and then understanding both
the whitespace in products,
but also being able
to respond quickly
to the different complaints,
or the different feedback
mechanisms, consumers
were providing to us.
One of the really cool
things we could do--
in one case, we
had a user that had
a team that spoke two
languages, but needed to operate
in 10 different countries.
It was very easy to
add a natural language
processing, a translation
API, on top of that
and then quickly use that team
to get their arms around much
bigger business.
We really feel like
where we're going
to fight in this space
with an army of capability
that we can quickly give
our teams distributed
around the world.
We can also incorporate
new data sets very quickly.
So a source like Twitter,
much more structured API,
directly bring it
in, correlate it
to other data sets
that are there.
When I was in the
government, we were doing
really cool things with tweets.
We could geolocate
based on text alone.
And at Colgate, we're finding
a lot of great information's
coming from the correlation
of disparate data
sets and the ability to
bring data out of the tools
that we have into a common
construct, and through using ML
and code where we need to.
Also, using Tableau or
the Google Data Studio
has been the most
helpful for users
that don't have a coding
background, because they've
been able to rearrange and
build their own dashboards.
They don't get stuck with
a static dashboard that
presupposes the question.
And they have the ability
to really explore the data
that they're working with.
Just to show the
example architecture
that we used for this
sentiment analysis,
you see a common repetition
of the Google Cloud Storage
capability throughout that.
That's because storing data
raw is an important lesson
learned in the past and
very relevant in this space,
as well.
When we are going out
and acquiring data
from a number of
sources, if we might
start on an e-commerce site,
ingest all the reviews.
But we might then need
to go to something
like a Kickstarter or an
Etsy to see where trends
might be starting and to follow
them down to their very source.
For that, we need a
lot of flexibility
to direct what I tell our
leadership is a spotlight
to go out and get us
the data that we need.
One of the most important
things is storage is cheap,
people are expensive,
and time is critical.
With that in mind, we
store everything raw
because we have to go back
to the original source data
and extract extra information
that we can find there.
Once it's there, we use
Cloud Pub/Sub, also setting
the stage for
streaming capabilities,
particularly important in
a supply chain environment.
But here, it allows for batch
processing for whenever reviews
arrive, Pub/Sub kicks
off a cloud function
that then scores
all the metrics,
produces all the
insight around the data,
pushes it back into another
cloud storage bucket,
and eventually into BigQuery.
The reason we do this
temporary storage
along these different
stages is because it
allows us to store data raw,
which our data scientists can
go back then and extract
extra information from.
And then finally, once it's in
BigQuery, from a CSO security
leader perspective,
it's very helpful.
It's an append-only database.
I can give my teams
a lot of freedom.
And by working closely with
Google's security teams
I can distribute this capability
across the company really
quickly and do so knowing that
the security is in a construct
that my SOC is monitoring and
my teams can use very quickly.
So I'd love to talk about
the details of this more.
I'd love to hear
stories about how others
are using this capability
to quickly move, understand,
and act on all the
information that's out there.
And thank you for your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]